how's it going my name is Priyanka so I
found it cause the story that was made
for me it's made by Colleen Stein it's
called muffin mark didn't I read our
daily our name at my baby I don't know
anyway you got a message for imagine
asking you to get a person for it if you
don't bring the potion you oh no my kid
will die but be aware the animals will
do whatever it takes to stop you if you
should fail the barrels and untrusted
statutes would take over the way god
damnit
I hate when they take over the world
[ __ ] barrels
I will not let them do it I will give
him the potion and then Martin will rub
your nipples all over them and then it
will all be okay I think it needs
all right I guess whoa Sasha ride away
doesn't it well I got my lantern ladies
and gentlemen and I don't trust you
why are in my bedroom why would I even
put one of you in my bedroom it makes
zero a light man why would I put it as a
[ __ ] painting of you
I do want to play a little I don't know
Carl again musky I don't know what the
[ __ ] okay cool all right
I don't trust this one second
whoa whoa oh [ __ ] me
early [ __ ] what all right oh [ __ ] man oh
wow
nope mmm there bro ain't looking
what the [ __ ] is he doing kind of
pungent [ __ ] alright that's bathing have
you anything all right that's the father
Jesus Christ what are you doing here
with all these people I don't know why
every talking into the same voice just
guys feeling nice fine I'll put you down
bro
what yeah I feel sexy
yeah look at this dog oh yeah yeah you
like that dog you like this doggy
oh yeah IFS good eye aunt Aggie you're
so sexy
I'm a bunny Mara [ __ ] well you
rehydrate I hide tiny bear for me it's
later [ __ ] alright it's creepy man I
don't like you man
alright spawn I think we're ready to go
in the other room unless there's like a
key or something I need fine here all
right I don't like be careful pay of
course I'm careful well we need a key
are you doing that damn
all right come on I bit my lip this
other day and it hurts so much I can
barely talk
it's like stings like a mother effer
come on where's the keep man
Oh a dagger oh no way I should stab the
breath be careful pay off car chases guy
all right
it's totally busy looking at this wall
so I'm sorry bro what the hell
baby's ass no maybe dad's okay hey look
at it
wait you could use this to kill it but
what it doesn't worry okay that's take
like the lid up there we go
well bronze I fear there is history that
ass is still really nice done all right
don't eat Mikey man all right there we
go
ow
Jacek I'd merely be careful Oh [ __ ]
bad Jam I throw Jade's it's kind of a to
you through me like about damn I wanna
sad superpowers
alright pity I see you on the other side
I see you in the sewers man
goddamn [ __ ] barrel on god dammit
what the hell is this I fought this by
there he wanted to steal my clothes
alright cool
[ __ ] floating barrel alright what do
you think about this situation maybe I
don't know why is mocked in I don't oh
[ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
no do it
rabbana don't look back ah got the bat
up there there you answer I'm sorry man
what's up hey they should I look down
down damn [ __ ] freaky [ __ ] man
so honey jump-scares a [ __ ] myth all
right whoa Bob holy mother of penis
all right hello ladies stop lying Cobb
please
oh whoa look at a whoa look at that so
much nudity I love it
oh I'm swimming around without vagina
I miss the fun oh man so sorry I left
him ah over here
I'm swimming around uh the vagina is on
their period apparently that is
disgusting uh what the hell man that is
a nasty [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] period in
vagina all right let's go here I guess I
do we have here whoa if you're reading
this I I have taken my life do not waste
your time looking for my body because
all I had was is what's here I hope you
found it useful Jacob I thank you gay
captain all right there we go
all right I got a key for
untrustable statues are talking about
when they talked about it I don't know
it doesn't matter
oh come on man [ __ ] ah Jesus penis
you [ __ ] barrel you try to frack in
front of me alright so here maybe Oh jam
I didn't even touch you stop this [ __ ]
okay I have your key man I put it in
your penis oh no come on
[ __ ] poopers damn you girl out damn
you girl [ __ ] intense [ __ ] man oh
come on [ __ ] my bad God dad I thought is
gonna make it oh well what can you do
you have to carry on yeah I will I will
carry on what Oh No
I pan it I can save you really just
follow me all right I'll do that someone
missed the tetris block here all right
whoa you let some time say wait one sec
forget just I don't even know what I
mean yeah in pail-head ye best [ __ ] ever
yeah yeah now what the hell do I do with
this
if the bro come back you can give it
alright I got your head bro whoa whoa
what do whoa
what do what yeah no I think it's bagged
a little bit actually
ah that's a shame I think I think the
door wait
okay then bug it off I'm the stupid Yi I
saved baby
I save you after I molested that dog I
was like yeah yeah whoa you thought I
was a pig no I'm a carousel yeah yeah
yeah I mean I mean
you can't do [ __ ] brah
god damn my voices like died of yeah oh
yeah yeah he's sexy I'll stay with you
man
alright I guess I go baby Wow now come
on this is your best you can do is that
your [ __ ] best barrel go the best I
cannot leave without rescuing mr. Sharon
huh what the [ __ ] you my man alright
here we go
well where the [ __ ] is mr. Sherr alright
today we can't repair they like it in
the storage later we can't pick it mr.
chair as well we just need to find Matt
didn't before you contacting Schmidt
check it won't be a problem that I
caught the only one who prevent us from
shopping it sir barrel a lot that's
letter bucket now I can leave thank you
you're coming with me
[Music]
I'm [ __ ] mad all right Barry I'll stay
with battles and fight them all right
good good that's good now we need to
find spawn Oh Gail Maxine I mean say
button and damn it's dark in here
hello you got [ __ ] me jet packs or
whatever that is hate that [ __ ] [ __ ] is
this tars how I hate you I need to find
a key here found it hey come on come on
I'm in a closet so I hate how it's
talking so [ __ ] creepy
dude hey Artie
[ __ ] that [ __ ] not anymore no I can fit
in yet no see you next episode of a meek
Sesame
what I don't want to that's great
George what the hell oh come on bull